في الغرب حيث يدعون التحضر
يبدو أنهم أقرب لقانون الغاب،
فالكبير منهم يتحين
الفرصة لأكل الصغير
، روسيا الدولة العظمى
تحاول بأي طريقة إضافة أوكرانيا
إلى حصتها،
روسيا تحاول استعادة أمجادها السوفييتية
لكن على حساب من؟
على حساب دولة صغيرة
لا تساوي جزءا صغيرا لدى الروس،
ألا يعلم الروس أن مساحة دولتهم
تعادل ما يقارب ضعف مساحة أوروبا
التي تحوي قرابة ٥٠ دولة
تشترك مصالح هذه الدول مع أوكرانيا
سياسيا واقتصاديا ورياضيا؟
ولماذا يستعرض الروس عضلاتهم على أوكرانيا؟
وهل يكون هذا لإثبات التحدي
مع الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية؟
والسؤال الأهم هو لماذا تريد روسيا
غزو أوكرانيا أساسا؟
الإجابة في دقائق هذا الفيديو...
يستعد قرابة ٢٠٠ ألف جندي
من القوات الروسية للحرب في أوكرانيا،
وهذا بالتأكيد ما يخشاه القادة الغربيون
وأوكرانيا نفسها.
ففي عام ٢٠١٤،
استولت روسيا على جزء من أوكرانيا
ودعمت الانفصاليين الذين بدأوا صراعًا
في مناطق واسعة شرقي البلد.
روسيا تنفي رسميا أي خطط كهذه
فما الذي يجري؟
أوكرانيا تلتقي في الحدود مع العديد من دول أوروبا،
وهي دولة مستقلة منذ تفكك الاتحاد السوفييتي،،،
لكن روسيا تحاول تحجيم أوكرانيا
شيئا فشيئا لتأخذها إليها مرة أخرة،
وتحاول منع انضمامها للناتو
أو تواجده على أرضها،،
وبالعودة إلى العام ٢٠١٤
حين استغل الروس عزل الأوكرانيين
لرئيسهم الموالي لروسيا،
واحتلوا شبه جزيرة القرم
فيما سيطر الانفصاليون المدعومون من روسيا
على مساحات شاسعة من الأراضي الشرقية لروسيا،،،
وبعد كل هذا تخرج تصريحات روسيا
بعدم وجود أي نية لهم لاحتلال أوكرانيا،،،
ما الذي يجعل العالم اليوم يؤكد وجود
تهديد حقيقي بالغزو؟
في الشرق لا يزال الصراع مستمرا إلى اليوم،
وتستمر روسيا بإرسال الدبابات والمدفعية والقناصة
إلى جبهة المتمردين،
أما ما يثير قلق أوكرانيا حقا
فهو وجود ٩٠ألف جندي روسي
على مقربة من حدودها،،
فماذا يفعل كل هذا العدد من الجنود على حدود دولة أخرى؟
وصحيح أن روسيا لم تعلن رسميا
أنها قررت الغزو، إلا أن المخابرات الأمريكية
تقول أن ما يصل إلى ١٧٥ألف
يمكن أن يشاركوا في الغزو
بداية من يناير ٢٠٢٢
ما هو المبرر للغزو إن حدث؟
تتهم روسيا أوكرانيا أنها نقلت ١٢٥ألف جندي
وهو نصف جيشها، إلى الشرق
لكن أليست تلك أرضاً أوكرانية ويحق لهم
التنقل حيث شاءوا؟ ..
بينما أصبح نصف مليون أوكراني في مناطق المتمردين
لديهم جوازات سفر روسية،
وبهذا فإنهم أصبحوا مواطنين روس،
ولذا لا يمكن التخلي عنهم كما تقول الحكومة الروسية
يا لهذا المكر الذي يستخدمونه!!!
وهنا يجدر بنا القول أن عدد الجيش الروسي
قرابة ٦ملايين جندي منهم جنود الاحتياط....
(وهذا العدد أكبر من سكان العديد من الدول في العالم)
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يحذر الغرب
من تجاوز الخطوط الحمراء..
فالغرب وعلى رأسهم أمريكا وبريطانيا
وحلف الناتو بأكمله، يقفون عسكريا واقتصاديا
مع أوكرانيا في الدفاع عن حقها وسيادتها،،،
فهل ينوي الغرب الدخول في الحرب عسكريا
فيما لو قررت روسيا الغزو؟
لا يبدو ذلك منطقيا لكن الغرب
أقرب إلى أن يستخدموا ورقة الضغط الاقتصادي...
وكل ذلك لا ينفي سيادة أوكرانيا،،
واستبداد روسيا التي تلجأ إلى القوة لإخضاع جارتها،،
فإلى أين ستصل النهاية؟
وهل تخضع أوكرانيا لقوة روسيا؟
أم أنه سيكون هناك حل سلمي؟